[Music]
have you changed your mind
or had any
insights since we last spoke or come to
any different conclusions related to
fasting yeah i mean i think because
you've done i mean for the record you've
done you've done a lot of fasting i mean
you have a lot of experience doing
right fasts of many different lengths
including with i don't know what the
longest fast is that you've done
probably 10 days 10 days yeah um
yeah i think that you know one thing
that i
absolutely learned through fasting uh is
the the
the enormous importance of strength
training throughout a fast it's
very easy you're gonna lose muscle mass
when you fast you have to accept that
so the question is how do you minimize
that damage how do you lose as little
muscle mass as possible and
strength training daily during a fast
has become an important part of that
but when you look at time restricted
feeding which is
or people call it intermittent fasting
although i don't i don't like that term
very much i think time restricted makes
more sense when you're just talking
about you know 16 or 18 hours
um i i i'm really starting to see a lot
of people who do that
excessively and who aren't necessarily
training correctly
they lose weight but they're losing
muscle
more than they would want to see and you
know
we just had a patient who we did a dexa
scan on last week um
and it was probably the first one we've
done in 18 months on him
and in that 18-month period his body
weight had not changed maybe he was a
bit lighter actually he might have lost
four pounds
but his body fat was
so high i almost fell off my chair and
he doesn't look
chubby right but he's it's it speaks how
much muscle he's lost so he
his body fat went from about 18 to 30
percent
yikes which was you know it's just a
totally unacceptable amount of fat for
someone his age
um and and his visceral fat went up
which i actually care more about than
body fat we can talk about that later
um but his visceral fat also went up so
you know this is a guy who has
religiously been doing his time
restricted
feeding every day but he doesn't really
lift weights you know he
he walks and you know does some yoga and
stuff like that but he's not doing
strength training so i think in a person
like that
there's a real downside to too much time
restricted feeding
and even for myself like in the last
four or five months i've been i
you know i did a dexa back in january
and i hadn't done one in
years and from the
from january to the last period that i
had done a dexa
my body weight was almost identical
maybe i was two pounds lighter this year
versus the last time
but my body fat was up
i think i went from 10 to 16 body fat
and again you could say well 16 is not
the end of the world but you know that
was a significant loss of muscle and
gain of fat
um and i i did wonder if that was just
too much because because i always
exercise in the morning but then don't
eat
so you you know to exercise and then not
provide yourself
with especially with when you're
strength training to provide yourself
with any amino acids
every single day to you know undergo
muscle protein synthesis
i think it's a little bit risky so i so
i've been looking at other strategies
around that right so for example
front loading the media question when
and then we'll come back to front
loading meals during that period of time
were you doing and this i may be
misremembering
but one one three day fast a month or
one
week long fast every quarter what was
the
frequency all of the above yeah i
probably spent
maybe two years doing seven days a
quarter maybe a year doing it three days
a month
um and then but in between it's also
doing lots of time restricted
um and honestly i think the daily time
restricted was a bit
more the issue because i think you can
relatively
you can really you know i think the
three-day fast a month
with a lot of lifting i didn't sense i
lost a lot of muscle
during that period of time but i think
every day
exercising in the morning not putting
calories in until later in the day
um it has to be it it has to be taken in
the context of an individual so
if you're someone who's 100 pounds
overweight or you have diabetes
it's a totally worthwhile trade-off to
lose muscle mass
because you're losing more fat mass
along the way yeah right so you are
going to technically get leaner with
that approach but when you take
a relatively healthy and lean individual
one has to be a little bit careful and
look for alternative ways to
sort of get the benefits of that fast
you